the list of top golfers joining a
breakaway tour sponsored by saudi arabia
is growing longer adding bryson
dischambeau and patrick reed according
to britain's telegraph they would join
phil mickelson dustin johnson sergio
garcia and louis oosthazen
these six players who have won a total
of 12 major championships are giving up
the pga tour in exchange for millions in
guaranteed money they're also leaving
themselves open accusations they are
linking themselves to an authoritarian
regime as charlie dagida shows us
good morning over the course of the next
few days some of the biggest names in
golf will be competing for one of the
biggest paychecks in golf but the battle
unfolding on the fairways and greens
here goes far beyond this little patch
of england
what's about to tee off today at the
centurion club north of london
could change the course of golf forever
six-time major champion phil mickelson
among a swelling number of stars lured
away from the pga by eye-watering sums
of saudi arabian money i understand that
many people have very strong opinions
and may disagree with my decision
at this time
this is
an opportunity that gives me a chance to
have
the most balance
in my life going forward and i think
this is going to do a lot of good for
the game
and a lot of good for his bank balance
he declined to confirm reports he cut a
deal for 200 million dollars just to
show up he was repeatedly grilled about
saudi arabia's human rights record i
don't condone human rights violations at
all i
i don't think
nobody here does
any throughout the world but those
violations haven't stopped him from
taking part
same with big hitters like sergio garcia
ian poulter lee westwood but none higher
ranked than former world number one
dustin johnson who defected from the pga
for reported 125
million dollar paycheck yeah but what
the consequences are going to be
obviously i can't comment on how the
tour is going to handle
the breakaway tour has driven a wedge
straight through the pga between those
staying loyal to the tour and those who
believe they deserve a bigger payout i
think it is an existential threat to the
way that golf has been run traditionally
since the 1960s ian carter's bbc sports
golf reporter and you're actually having
big names resigning from the pga tour
who would ever have seen that coming
that's huge right i think it is i think
it's i think it's very significant even
more significant the fact it's being
bankrolled by a saudi regime accused of
appalling human rights abuses including
the brutal murder of journalist jamal
khashoggi saudi arabia is
investing billions and billions of
dollars into reputation improvement
across the world a pr campaign known as
sports washing or what human rights
watches adam cool calls image laundering
well saudi arabia has had a terrible
human rights record for many years it's
a place where
basic freedoms have never been
especially respected
as for the future of the pga tour
commissioner jay monahan has repeatedly
threatened a lifetime ban for players
participating in saudi-backed events but
the list continues to grow so the money
is out of this world nathan murphy hosts
the golf weekly podcast nobody knows
really where this is going to end
but certainly it is the greatest threat
and rival that the pga tour has ever
faced
it came as a surprise to say the least
when dustin johnson said he'd be taking
part in a tournament just a few months
ago he was one of the most vocal
opponents in the end he said i had to do
what's best for my family
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta north
of london
i guess money talks there's many talks
looking forward to the women's tour
there yeah right happy new year
yes